how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
Marvel and everything relating to the
MCU today we have some guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 news specifically around
when we can expect it to be released in
theaters the release of guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 has been and still pretty
much is a big mystery because of the
rescheduling of guardians 3 because of
James Gunn of course James Gunn was
fired and then rehired so guardians 3
which was supposed to be out in July of
this year got pushed back and
unfortunately when James Gunn got
rehired he was already working on the
Suicide Squad so we have to wait till
after he's done with the Suicide Squad
until he can work on guardians 3 but
just yesterday he talked about when to
expect guardians 3 on Twitter and it's
not an exact date but it is something so
I'll break it down in this video but
first if you're new be sure to subscribe
so you can stay up to date on everything
relating to the MCU and so you can enter
this week's Funko pop giveaway for a
spider-man Funko pop all you got to do
is subscribe like the video leave a
comment down below to enter I'm picking
a winner on Monday so James Gunn talking
about the guardians 3 release date came
on Twitter if you follow James Gunn on
Twitter or Instagram you know that he's
pretty active and he actually does reply
back to a lot of people that at him and
in fact he ends up confirming a lot of
things on Twitter and Instagram and
yesterday on Twitter he gave us a little
bit of a tease of when to expect
guardians 3 and it happened with a tweet
from AMC Theaters they said guardians of
the galaxy was the highest grossing
domestic film of 2014 with 333 million
writer director James Gunn and the
entire cast will be back for volume 3 in
2021 now seemingly AMC Theaters just
confirmed that guardians 3 is coming in
2021 which would be next year however
James Gunn replied to the tweet saying
thanks for the love AMC Theaters
although we won't be in theaters until a
little after 2021 unless they've been
filming without me now a lot of people
and a lot of websites immediately took
this to mean that guardians of the
galaxy 3 is not coming until 2022
however James Gunn had something to say
about that somebody responded to the
tweet by saying websites are frantically
writing James Gunn and
as guardians of the galaxy three won't
release until 2022
but James Gunn responded I didn't say
2022 seemingly backing up what AMC
Theatres said about 2021 now this is
kind of confusing and really there are
three things that could be happening
here
one is that guardians 3 is going to be
coming up in 2021
AMC tweeted it saying 2021 I am DB right
now has it listed for 2021 although some
people can go in and edit IMDB but in a
recent article by Collider they also
mentioned that guardians 3 would be in
2021 what James Gunn could have meant by
saying although we won't be in theaters
until a little after 2021 it could mean
that it's simply not going to come in
the beginning of 2021 and more likely
coming at the end and if that were to
happen this would be the lineup for 2021
the Eternals in February shang-chi in
May and the third spider-man film in
November now many people have been
wondering for a while if Marvel Studios
is going to do four movies a year they
certainly have the capability to do it
and they're actually doing it in 2022
there are four movies coming out from
Marvel Studios and if they wanted the
movie to come out before Thor love and
thunder it would be the perfect
opportunity and perfect placement after
all James Gunn already confirmed that
the original release date for guardians
volume 3 was supposed to be May of this
year
so clearly the plan before was to have
the guardians film first before Thor
love and thunder and the reason that
they might not have announced guardians
3 for 2021 right now is because James
Gunn technically can't work on guardians
3 until he is finished with Suicide
Squad however he's pretty much admitted
that the script is for the most part
done it's been through several drafts
already and they're pretty much ready to
go for filming they just have to wait
until he's done so perhaps Marvel is
just waiting to announce it until he's
done with the Suicide Squad now the
second option is that it could be in
2023 as I mentioned right now Marvel
Studios already has four films coming
out in 2022 due to the coronavirus
having them reshift their schedule in
2022 we have Thor love and thunder in
February Doctor Strange 2 in March black
panther 2 in May and Captain Marvel in
July so perhaps they'll skip over 2022
altogether and go straight to 2020
three this would definitely be very
unfortunate but it's definitely a
possibility but the third option is that
James Gunn could simply be trolling and
it could in fact be coming in 2022 yes
there are four films coming in 2022 but
the last one ends in July that's still
basically half a year to do another
Marvel film now if I had to make an
educated guess I would probably say that
guardians 3 is going to be coming out in
2021 Marvel Studios just hasn't
announced it yet because they can't
until James Gunn finishes on the Suicide
Squad if that's not the case then I
would probably say that it's going to be
coming in 2023 unfortunately but let's
hope it's 2021 but let me know what do
you think on this what do you make of
these tweets be sure to let me know your
thoughts about this in the comments down
below and don't forget to like this
video and subscribe stay up to date on
all things relating to the MCU for live
updates you can follow me on Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof